In this problem, singly-hyphenated words,
we're going to test our ability to use the or operator
and the ability to group regular expressions.
And here we're going to write a regular expression
that matches 2 types of words, normal words, such as alice and bob,
and also those with a single hyphen, such as super-irvin.
We, however, won't perfectly match a string such as super-mega-irvin,
so we need to write a regular expression that perfectly matches alice,
bob, super-irvin but doesn't match super-mega-irvin.
Well, one way to think about it is we have 2 types of regular expressions,
one that matches normal words, or one that matches a word with a single hyphen.
Let's do one at a time.
First let's do the one that matches a normal word.
This regular expression will match 1 or more occurrences of lower-case letters.
Okay, let's move on to the single hyphenated words.
A single hyphenated word has 3 parts,
a word, a hyphen, and another word,
so here I match a word, a hyphen, and then another word.
Really I want to match either of these,
and in order to do this, I'm going to have to group them, and in Python
we group them using parentheses, and don't forget
the silly question mark colon notation as well.
And here we go as a regular expression.
Notice that I listed the hyphenated words first
because the way find all works is that it first checks
to see if this matches the left side of the operator and then the right side.
And if I'm running find all, I'd rather have it return the hyphenated word
super-irvin instead of first checking if the word matches just super,
then seeing that hyphen doesn't match anything, and then returning irvin.
I'd rather get the whole thing, super-irvin.